jumped out the window yeah
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
right here
you guys talk to the homeowners I don't
think there's anybody in here
right on the other side
breakfast for you inside the house
where did this occur
what's the address
let me ask you let me ask you uh where
the keys inside the truck yeah so we
just got like the keys were there but it
wasn't in the ignition
um Okay so
it's stolen that's delvis Gonzalez
I'm getting his info now
don't worry about two different cases
here yeah okay so keys were inside the
truck you hear you hear the truck and
then you came after the reference yeah
so I can't I'm like first I thought I'd
come out like slowly
amen
there's a camera in the truck okay
the first question we hit our truck yeah
like no I mean oh no I was on the phone
I heard you saw it and no I didn't see
it I'm gonna lie and I'm talking to him
like because I'm thinking like which way
do you go or go I'm like I think he's
because he's running off the back side
so I'm like yeah so I'm like oh he went
East then I hear like a
and then after that and then you came
over here one of these guys that works
at this company right here because they
know the company because right across
the street they come over like yo you're
a guy I'm like our God I'm like no
that's our truck that's like I said over
here and then he was just talking oh he
uh hit a car did you how did you follow
him here
okay
cut across track and he ended up running
and hit this guy do you know this guy or
no okay is he gonna be okay I guess
they're treating him together he's
getting transported oh no it's Cisco I
was gonna say I know it's probably
teleported was the vehicle parked or was
he mobile okay
so
um
and you're trying to get the video I'm
strong but it's not gonna loaded
he ripped off the actual yeah that's
right yeah we're able to get the camera
and upload it I don't know this is my
this is our personal business so I truly
don't know but I do know it saves every
type of clip so whenever to pull the
footage it'll pop up where are you able
to pull the footage from like is there a
hard drive
literally right there so he said he was
inside the RV which is their office he
hears the heart the truck starting and
he's like wait he sees all his people
inside it's like the house starting the
truck the keys were inside the truck
like not in the ignition but they were
inside as soon as you heard the trouble
wanted to go outside
so he followed the guy out in the truck
so like right there
and then shortly after he heard the
practice
guys
[Applause]
thank you
today
any major injuries
and see the gym
yeah yeah
no not this guy this is the victims
[Applause]
foreign
thank you
it's not very high
[Applause]
and this is where we started the hotel
um
thank you
just to verify again how are you coming
I was coming this way this way yeah
I was just coming from work yes
okay sir you can please do me a favor
top part all you're gonna do
this bottom part right here you're just
exactly what happened this little thing
right here just what happened you know
you the part was you were on the lot
that saw a male occupied and travel
whatever Direction
not not all of this it's just from the
moment that the part was stolen
purple
you ran all the way over here
so that's what I'm like but it's just
because you didn't get hurt
but that's at least a lot worse
over yeah
paperwork
sorry I don't mean we really need that
okay but someone's following
oh he was parked over here oh he was
parked on that side
the primary's still here the primary is
still here
no no I heard the sergeant Center yeah
I got the damage to the house
it was like a driver
did you need the keys
yeah
before I got back
okay so they left
so they put it what I got back to
and then I hear
he's like
he's one of our guys
okay
yeah
take it but
foreign
rotation if he doesn't want to pay for
it
you see
foreign
once